who'll be the next president of france
emmanuel macron bids for re-election in
the shadow of war in ukraine
but candidates from the far right and
far left say he's out of touch with the
french population
will the voters prove them right
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
mohammad jim zhum five years ago
emmanuel macron was a newcomer to french
politics he swept aside the traditional
left-right political divide by forming a
centrist party and becoming the youngest
ever president now the 44-year-old is
the incumbent seeking re-election
sunday's first round of voting is
happening in the shadow of russia's
invasion of ukraine
macron held his only campaign rally last
saturday outside paris he promised to
defend europe's democracy while raising
pensions and cutting corporate taxes
opinion polls suggest a repeat of 2017
when macron faced marine le pan in the
second round the far-right candidate has
since toned down her previous statements
against immigration instead she's
focused her campaign on the high cost of
living
both are facing late challenge from the
far left we'll bring in our guests in a
moment first natasha butler reports from
lille
is one of france's best-known
politicians a fiery orator and former
trotskyist the far-left party leader has
spent years on the margins of french
politics but melancho's fortunes are
changing opinion polls suggest he could
make it to the second round of the
presidential election at a rally in
lille he said if elected he'd end in
equality fight climate change and tackle
the cost of living crisis
millions of french people are being
strangled by the rising cost of living
and fuel prices millions of french
people so the role of those who lead the
nation is to fix this
supporters say he's the antithesis of
emmanuel macron whom shawn once
nicknamed the president of the rich
it's been a difficult five years for
many people so as far as i'm concerned
we can't re-elect emmanuel macron
melanchol embodies anti-capitalism
pro-workers rights we're sick of
factories shutting in france we want a
strong europe and melon sean's the only
one with answers
one of the main reasons that milosha is
doing so well in this presidential
election is because france's traditional
left-wing socialist party is doing badly
for decades the socialist party was a
political force that created presidents
but the arrival of the centrist macro in
2017 and a shift among voters to the
political right has left the socialist
party in tatters and its presidential
candidate and idalgo floundering in the
polls the socialist party still has
local
mayors but on the national level it has
lost any appeal because it's lost
a program it's lost ideas it lost the
battle of ideas and and francois
hollande's presidency is seen
in its legacy as a moment of weakness uh
in terms of ideas in terms of proposals
in terms of also answers to the problems
of globalization of
the changes
in the society
with most parties on the left including
the greens trailing in the polls milosha
is expected to reap the majority of
left-wing votes few people expect him to
win the presidency but making it past
the first round could signal that
france's left is ready for a revival
natasha butler al jazeera lil
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in paris hamid sriet a
political commentator and researcher on
french economic affairs
in san malo jacques reynolds a senior
research fellow at the global policy
institute and a specialist in economic
and social policy
also in paris jazin weber a program
coordinator with the german marshall
fund of the u.s paris office and an
expert in european security issues a
warm welcome to you all and thanks for
joining us today on inside story jacques
let me start with you today where do
things stand in the election right now
opinion polls are suggesting a repeat of
2017 when president macron faced marine
le pen in the second round do you think
that's what we're going to see happen
it looks like it yeah at this stage it
looks like it
macron
was well in the lead when the war
started at 32 percent now is down to 26
27
but marine le pen
has risen from 17 to 22 in that space
and the only other contender could be
jean-luc melenchon
who last time
rose quite uh five points in the last
week he's not 15 around 15 16 but i
don't think he will be able to overtake
marine le pen so it looks like uh
macron le pen
jewel for the second round
but with a closer
margin
a narrower margin than was expected uh
but only even two weeks ago so that's
the main point is the rise and rise of
marine le pen in the last couple of
weeks and uh
can explain why that has happened at the
later stage
but if you want i can uh i can start now
yeah i know i'll
jacques i'll actually get back to you
with a question on that in just a moment
um let me ask you how much has russia's
invasion of ukraine
upended president macron's plans for
what he had hoped to accomplish in the
first half of this year and how how much
is the shadow of the conflict in ukraine
looming over this election cycle so
maybe erin said with the first question
thank you very much for that so um
in this context it is very important to
know that france is currently holding
the rotating presidency of the council
of the european union and when you are
holding this function or when you have
this role that means that you have kind
of a coordinating role it can give
some ideas for what can be done on the
european level
and
when macro presented this program in
december it was clear that he wanted to
put the focus
on everything related to european
sovereignty but also
to
economic recovery as well as
creating a feeling of belonging to
europe and with the ukraine crisis
crisis in terms of foreign policy it was
particularly um the part on sovereignty
that is becoming more and more important
so as you might know um since his
suburban speech in 2017 macro has always
pitched the idea of european strategic
autonomy
lately changed the wording to
sovereignty but the idea of this is
basically that the eu itself is able to
make its independent decisions
based on its interests and of course
where possible in cooperation with
partners and over quite a long time
fellow europeans were kind of kind of
wary of this concept thought that it's
kind of a hyper activism of macron but
then when the war in ukraine kicked in
um other europeans
painfully realized that this idea of
having a europe that is kind of a bit
more sovereign in terms of energy supply
and then defense and can really leverage
its his tools
um
yeah that this is maybe not the worst
idea and when we saw what europe has
done that is basically putting macron's
concept of sovereignty into practice so
of course it was not only him who has
achieved that but
yeah that's a clear success also knowing
that macron is the only channel of
communication that europe still has
for russia and leave it here um if you
want to ask a follow-up no i'll i'll get
i'll get back to you on that point
actually in a moment too um hamid let me
ask you from your vantage point um how
the electorate is responding to what's
going on in ukraine i mention this
because you know president macron has
been heavily involved in trying to
broker some type of diplomatic solution
to the crisis in ukraine um he has been
reaching out repeatedly to uh russian
president putin he's been shuttling
around
trying to come up with some type of
solution is that something that that's
hurting him or helping him when it comes
to voters and when it comes to this
election when it comes to the voters at
the beginning of the ukrainian crisis
macro has benefits of course
during his election but at the end of
the day
the french voters will see
if their salaries have increased or not
i think this is the main important point
we've seen empty presidency of the
european union and we've seen as well
the domination of the american
leadership guidance in the
european parliament so french people are
very uh
have been doubted by the presidency of
macro and during his last five
uh uh
reigns of the the french presidency so i
believe that the uh the
french people
will not of course
support uh this war about the russian
invasion but the end of but at the end
of the day they are very worried about
the social uh uh
for the social situation and the
economic situation they are suffering
in france we've never seen in france
people uh i've never seen personally in
france people are going uh uh to bring
the food from the bean in france in
paris so i live in the popular area
which is 19
arrogismo in france and the the the
economic and social situation is worse
than before
um jacques i want to pick up on the
point you were starting to make in your
last answer which is um the reasons for
the sudden surge in the polls for marine
le pen uh so i want to ask you first of
all um what are some of the reasons for
that and and secondly the fact that
marine le pen has softened some of her
rhetoric around topics like islam and
like euro skepticism is that something
that is helping her right now to to win
potential voters outside of her typical
solid base
yes indeed but the thing is that as uh
amir was mentioning the people at first
were very concerned about the war and
marine le pen lost some point because
she's so pro putin she's a great putin
supporter has even reiterated recently
that the best of life of france would be
russia but
the fact is that people are now more
concerned about the consequences of the
war than the war and the consequences on
the cost of living and the cost of
living has been the hobby horse of
marine le pen in the last few months
she's campaigned on that she has uh
she did not
highlight her positions on race and
finish she suffered her image and
concentrated on the cost for people who
find it hard to make ends meet and she
has a lot of support among the working
classes unlike eczema for example
a lot of extremist voters we can see the
working areas the walking parts of
france like the north of france she's
very popular there and also she made a
very good campaign no big meetings uh
she traveled stayed close to the people
and
one factor which is very important is
that eric zebu with his radical
positions has made her look soft look
cuddly she has a better image now people
like
46 percent of the french people thinks
that
that she understands people like them it
used to be 22
in 2017 and now she's developed an image
the image of the woman next door who
will look after will be very helpful and
look after your cats when you're away
and she's actually made a big of the
fact that she's she loves cats she's
become the cat the cat breeder so she
has a much softer image but at the same
time and that's my main concern is that
a policies
uh
on which she hasn't been challenged much
by the media and she has not taken part
in many debates policies are still hard
i think that uh
marine le pen is a woof in ships
clothing and we can talk about the
preseason immigration and europe and on
the economy they would be damaging uh
for france uh for france's economy and
for france's standing in europe i think
it would be a victory of marine le pen
would be equip would it be
more damaging even right the european
you heard jacques there talk about the
opinion he was expressing was that a le
pen presidency would be damaging um for
uh france's standing in europe i want to
ask you what would a le pen presidency
mean for europe well le pen presidency
would be very bad news for europe that
is for sure um maybe to start from a bit
like an integration and institutional
perspective um le pen has or had until
the brexit referendum actually always
lobbied for a brexit and underlined that
this would be a good idea but her
narrative has changed i mean in fact
what she's advocating for now is kind of
leaving the eu but staying inside
because she says that she wants um to
reinstall the primacy of french and
national law over eu law so basically eu
law would not even or would not anymore
be applied in eu members or in france
which basically means you're just in a
loose grouping
of states that doesn't have any uh
regulatory power and that is also what
makes um the core of
the european union from a bit from a pro
broader perspectives
this
le pen victory would be very bad news
for europe because any deeper
integration project would immediately
be ended or would just not be pursued
and particularly
in the foreign and security policy that
would be extremely complicated because
you always need unanimity among member
states to pursue projects here so
if there is a french way waiter on
anything
the recent geopolitical awakening of the
eu that we have just seen would have
been a short momentum that
would unfortunately only make it to
history books
hamid um eric zimmer sorry hamid i want
to ask you something about first
something that jacques was mentioning he
was saying that the candidacy of eric
zamore
essentially makes marine le pen look
more relatable or perhaps more palatable
to voters i want to ask you about that
you know eric zimmer is somebody who's
twice been convicted for inciting uh
racial or religious hatred the fact that
he is running does that is that
something that's normalized marine le
pen for for other voters that's
something that has made her perhaps more
palatable to other voters yeah exactly
that is true
i do agree with jack uh she she was
normalized of course by the eric zimmer
the candidate because he was more
extremist
of her
so i believe that eric zimmer uh
she was at the beginning of the the
campaign criticizing the the posture of
eric zimo saying that he is in a racist
guy islamophobic guy
she
changed her speech about the integration
of the french muslim people
we know everybody knows how eric zumu
criticized islam and on islamism
he was saying is removed that the french
muslim people has to leave the faith and
the religion but
i would like to come back to the point
or about the uh the marilyn penn engine
and macro uh don't forget that emmanuel
macro and marvel le pen have the same
economic program as she is a liberal and
he is a liberal the only candidate who
really proposed a social reform is
johnny cuminosho who wants to of course
increase
the minimum salaries for the french
people and he knows how french people
during
the macron's presidency have been
suffering uh considerably uh i would
like as well to make uh to to
to uh reach uh to raise sorry an
important point about the yellow vest
movement uh the the ideology of the
yellowest movement in france is still
there is still in the sound and in the
heart of the french people in france uh
i think uh the crisis is more is a
deeper than than the the french election
uh uh days in france uh an uh democratic
crisis which will have to be uh resolved
uh today the the fifth uh regime of the
republic is now uh finished and that's
why uh the the democracy the cri the
democracy crisis
is uh
has to be resolved in france jacques um
hamid just mentioned uh jean-luc
melenchon and we heard in natasha
butler's report earlier in the program
that perhaps his political fortunes may
be changing now do you think that is the
case and could he potentially make it to
the second round as a candidate i think
it's a bit difficult last time he was
very close to
marine le pen becoming in third position
but
last time there were no green candidates
and no communist candidate and they've
been eating it to
and they have voters of
representing about seven
seven eight percent you don't know
exactly
and obviously if they decided to uh vote
for george bellancho jealous
would have a chance to come second but i
doubt it i would like to come back on
the point of uh amid and it is the
climate in france at the moment is that
there is a kind of a
democratic wariness i would say people
say okay we have elections but things
don't change it's always more is the
same thing yeah it's true we are part of
european union a free liberal market etc
and governments can't do too much
because of the international constraints
so there's a desire on the part of
people to overthrow the table to kick
the thing it's a bit like the feeling
there was at the time of brexit in
britain where people needed a scapegoat
and at the moment it seemed that maybe
the scapegoat could be eminent
himself even though uh contrary to what
amid say he's not he hasn't got the same
policies as
marine le pen and he's not a neo-liberal
he is a social liberal
advocates the social market economy but
uh it's not a neoliberal and we can see
in his last meeting
you know that somebody went too far on
the right by saying pensions should rise
to 65 and people getting supplementary
benefits should have some kind of
involvement in the world of okay trading
not obligatory one but training but at
the same time he's made sure that he
realizes that if he is to win he has to
earn votes on the left there is a is
some more social measures such as
raising uh the minimum pension and so on
quite a few measures go
towards helping and
if you look at this record you realize
that the french are not doing too badly
compared to the other the energy prices
in france have risen by four percent in
the rest of the eu it's 29
in britain they're present by 54
but the french always like to think that
you know it's terrible in equal we are
one of the most least unequal countries
i'm sorry
jacques i'm sorry to interrupt you it's
just we are starting to to run out of
time i i do want to ask jazeen another
question here um
you you wrote a piece recently in which
you said i'm going to quote it macron is
the most europhile president that france
has perhaps ever seen and the quest for
european strategic autonomy has
characterized his foreign policy over
the last five years i know that you were
talking about some aspects of this uh in
an earlier answer but how much has
president macron transformed the eu well
um
i would say if you had asked that
question to me in 2019 or before the
covert crisis i would say not really
because the call for european strategic
autonomy didn't resonate in his fire in
his
first years of presidency but that
completely changed with covert and the
recovery plan when europeans basically
discovered that they are completely
dependent on supply chains and need to
step up their own capacities and
capabilities
to deal with these challenges and also
what i think
from a foreign policy and defense policy
perspective is particularly interesting
is that his narrative of european
strategic autonomy and strengthening
european sovereignty has now made it
into the language of the institutions so
ozil fondly and the
mission president xia michel president
um of the council they're all using this
word learning and that basically shows
that there is kind of a change in
thinking on how the eu approaches global
global challenges and also when you're
looking at what was achieved
in terms of new defense initiatives for
example i would say my course track
record is quite good so
for example we now have a new rapid
deployment force in the strategic
compass the strategic compass is a
document which is kind of a strategic
guideline that was just adopted in the
end of march and that is deeply
characterized also by
french influence so i would say he has
transformed the eu in terms of methods
and also has given an important impetus
to the eu
to
see itself and to start understanding
itself as a geopolitical actor but he
has also
transformed europe because europeans are
now working differently together not
only in the eu but also in coalitions of
the willing
hamid we only have about a minute and a
half left i just want to ask you about
the fact that president macron
you know he really swept aside the
traditional left-right political divide
when it comes to
french politics by forming this centrist
party is that something that has
completely remade french politics well i
think macron is out of fetch uh we've
seen his old policies uh
in france during the the the his
presidency but i believe that the the
absenteeism in france it's very
important today more than 60 percent of
the french people maybe will not vote
people have been deceived by the
presidency of emmanuel macro and this is
will of course increase the democratic
crisis in france and i'm very worried
about the political situation in the
political map in france uh this is a i
mean a huge uh warring for the french
elites and if we
if emmanuel macron will not take
seriously uh the social problems in
france and resolve the uh
protestation of the yellow vest in
france uh this is will be of course his
presidency his presidency sorry will be
a disaster for the french economy and
the the political situation will be
istanbul
all right this will of course
destabilize the whole european union all
right well we have run out of time so
we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thank you so much to
all of our guests hamid shriek jasin
weber and jacques
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
muhammad jim joham and the whole team
here in doha bye for now
[Music]